[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to why do
we lie about Santa Claus just get going
before I bring the Easter Bunny form too
I mean when you get down to it it is
such a strange idea all the parents as
well as pretty much all the world lies
about the existence of this fictional
character and there's no given time the
kids are supposed to be told they either
sort of figure it out on their own or
their parents tell them when they think
they're ready I mean the idea is
charming that magical character can be
in your house leaving you gifts but
doesn't it inevitably have to meet with
the jarring truth don't a lot of kids
have to go through heartbreak and
sadness when they're told there is no
Santa Claus okay most kids take it okay
but there's definitely some that are
just destroyed by that fact the idea of
finding out that there's no Santa for
some kids it's like finding out there's
no God it's pretty heavy stuff to have
sync yet so why do we do it why do we
lie to their faces when at one point we
have to acknowledge that we lied to
their faces well there's a couple
different ways of looking at it first
off for the kids who get older and
figure it out for themselves they often
want to save face and not feel like
they've been taken advantage of so they
try not to let it bother them as much
and to be fair with age it probably
doesn't bother them that much if they're
old enough to figure out the reality
they're usually old enough not to let
emotionally cripple them
but what about the kids who don't figure
it out well many are told that they can
now partake in a new kind of magic the
kind of magic that involves keeping the
illusion alive for other kids because
hey magic is an illusion and it's
unlikely you were heartbroken when you
found out how they saw a woman in half
if anything you respected the illusion
even more Santa can kind of be the same
way especially if you have younger
siblings suddenly you can be the one
creating the fantasy and putting on the
show you can be the one creating and
sharing the stories and if not with your
siblings and with any other kids you
come across
you now have the ability to no longer be
the audience member but rather the
weaver of the illusion itself you can
create as opposed to witness and that's
a great feeling for anyone but that
still doesn't answer the question of why
why do we continue to lie about it
recently it hit me why the illusion of
Santa is not only a good thing but
actually an important thing really think
about all the surprises life that's
thrown at you just when you think you've
got it all figured out you have all the
answers a bit of truth you never
expected falls in your lap and changes
everything as many of us have noticed
change is hard and there's been far too
many times we come across a situation
that's fooled us a person who did
something we thought they could never do
or our minds that you've held for years
now has to be totally different in light
of something that's occurred in your
environment everybody has to go through
these rough times at some point in their
life where someone's perception of
reality is suddenly destroyed and
everything becomes uncertain what else
was I wrong about what other surprises
could be around the corner that can make
me look foolish
what should I now question and be afraid
of the Santa lie if you think about it
is our first way of dealing with that
it's a way of saying yes this wasn't
what you thought it was but it's all
right the world didn't blow up you still
have so many things to be thankful for
and Christmas somehow it's still just as
wonderful as it was before
in fact the discovery of the illusion
and your chance to now partake in it
might even make Christmas a little
better for you the Santa lie is a way of
adapting and accepting a way to see that
if something you thought was true was
suddenly false you can find out that not
only can you choose not to be damaged by
it but you can actually grow stronger
from it you can use your knowledge of
truth to help spread happiness and do so
knowing that those who you're charming
with the illusion will one day grow up
to do the same in a world that teaches
us it's not good to lie this is an
example of not only alive at works but
works because it has to be broken at one
point the children have to know the
truth
the majority of adults in the world know
the truth about Santa Claus and
discovering it there was no Wars or
bloodshed although that would be
hilarious and it shows that our core
that we at least have the seeds of
wanting to adapt and wanting to
understand and make ourselves stronger
to
the hearts truth find the positive side
to it and turn into something wonderful
all by simply looking at from a
different point of view it's an
acknowledgement that we can handle the
truth if we're simply smart enough to
find the correct way of looking at it
and what can start off to be terrible
and hurtful can actually turn out to be
something greater than you even imagined
it could be
and for totally different reasons so go
ahead lie to your kids make up stories
tell tall tales say you saw Sant in your
living room or whatever it's not
building them up for a big letdown it's
allowing them to realize how good it can
feel to believe in something and that
the revelation of the truth doesn't
necessarily destroy it it can actually
make it stronger
because there's so many details you can
play with and so many stories you can
add and so many things you can change
all these create your own unique fantasy
and giving your child their own unique
fantasy one that will result in a memory
that's distinctly theirs and no one
else's it's one of those rare lies where
the discovery of the fact only seems to
make it last longer and make us love it
even more
[Music]
and well rad the Tooth Fairy isn't real
either understand critic and clearly
your parents need to watch you fall
[Music]
[Applause]